Alright, Steph.
Ready?
Stephen Curry.
Do not rely on him
to run your team.
He's about 5' 6''.
Looks like a
little kid.
150 lbs
soaking wet.
That is when I first
really understood
I'm different.
How did I get here?
I was the undersized
scrawny kid
that was just trying
to figure out
how to make it.
Steph Curry is hurt.
I was overwhelmed
by everything.
How would
I respond?
Let the work begin.
When you are
an underdog,
you have to take
what is yours.
Get buckets!
Davidson College
for the
sweet sixteen.
It's not about
proving
other people wrong.
It's about proving
himself right.
And that feeling of
being underrated
will always be
part of the drive that
keeps me going.